heureusement il ya le home studio avant
de retourner en cabine
est-ce que c'était compliqué du coup de
finir le p à la maison un petit peu
parce que ya passé de connexion une main
que tu as en studio avec le ton âge et
ce en quoi donc pour faire déjà
comprendre des choses artistiquement au
téléphone à quelqu'un qui vont ensuite
devoir les refaire
techniquement sur son ordinateur entre
guillemets c'est une méga compliqué
parce que tu as un intermédiaire entre
ya un truc qui vient casser le change et
un fond du temps et il faut savoir
expliquer des choses qui sont difficiles
à expliquer au téléphone et en plus moi
je suis nul en technique donc je ne sais
pas expliquer les choses avec des vrais
termes je fais des bruits jeter des
lattois du thym ou éclore au lieu-dit
reins filtrent je vais lui dire tu fais
un truc comme ça et tout donc au
téléphone c'est encore plus souvent
faire je pense que c'est surtout
difficile pour ménager son de comprendre
les instructions je lui donne pour les
arrangements et pour le mix à distance
ça c'est vraiment le méga plan dès la
première phase mais prod même que j'aime
à prod
je travaille l'écriture je travaille
chez moi nuit est ensuite allé
enregistrer en en confinement il n'y a
pas de structure comment faire
heureusement il ya le home studio
c'est con parce que quand on est chez
soi on a des fois des meilleures idées
que quand on est allé quand on est sorti
de son cocon et qu' on essaie à vous de
chercher des mots ou là qu'on est un
petit peu diverti distrait par d'autres
choses là on est chez soi ça fait 15
jours que je suis dans la promo de
maison et j'ai l'impression d'avoir été
beaucoup plus clairement ce que je
voulais dire que si j'avais été comme
que par exemple le chocolat où il y
avait beaucoup plus de morceaux est
beaucoup plus de promo donc c'est pas
dégueulasse
ouais c'est beaucoup de travail quand
même et dans un esprit tu vois tu devais
aussi un petit peu vite fou parce que
c'est le même espace toute la journée
les mêmes questions et surtout pour ma
copine et qu'on peut voir juste derrière
qui subit depuis trois jours les mêmes
trucs
oui oui blue bubble des petits bouchons
protégez vos oreilles quand vous êtes en
concert les
les décibels sont très hautes et les
basses sont très fortes
les fréquences sont fortes aussi alors
le morceau que j'ai le plus envie jouer
en concert le jour où on fait des
concerts c'est évidemment show jeu j'ai
enfin voilà y'a pas beaucoup
d'explications le morceau est fait pour
ça et défoncé [ __ ] avec les gens qui
m'ont fierté d'aider des français tu as
press ap / en chaîne un petit soleil
pour que les gens deviennent die tu
valises et tu fais bosser la rive un
écran géant derrière avec michel drucker
qui dit merci tout ça c'est le retour au
live ça va être incroyable
pourquoi 18 mètres michel drucker à la
fin de le paix déjà tout simplement tout
le monde sait que j'aime beaucoup le
personnage il s'avère qu'ils m'avaient
envoyé un message vocal je les
enregistre et donc ce message vocal est
le vrai et pas du tout mis en scène sa
les roméo c'est un fan numéro 1 de
vivement dimanche
bonjour michel comment tu vois alors je
vais le dire un mot quand même
et oui de temps de paix entendre le son
de ma voix à la fin d'un titre d'euros
elvis t'imagines le cadeau tu me fais
mais j'ai beaucoup aimé d d d d d d d d
d d d
ddd confiné j'espère qu'on va vite se
revoir après lé déconfinement des dvd
des conflits nés comme se dit si bien le
sélect meilleur gros bisous
du coup voilà c'était comme elvis pour
bruce depuis ma cuisine derrière moi la
faim derrière nous de la verdure
merci au revoir
[Musique]